[Music]
ah
humanity it's a train wreck but i can't
look away
it's 1843 and a debate is raging among
physicians about one of the most common
killers of women
child bed fever childbed fever strikes
within days of giving birth
killing more than 70 of those infected
and nobody knows what causes it
obstetrician charles meeks has a theory
having observed abdominal inflammation
in patients who go on to develop the
fever
he claims this inflammation is the cause
of
childbed fever much of the medical
establishment
supports his theory oh come on
they really leave me no choice but to
teach them some
[Music]
skepticism
that's better now means
your argument is based on a fallacy the
false cause
fallacy correlation does not imply
causation when two phenomena regularly
occur
together one does not necessarily
cause the other so you say women who
have
inflammation also come down with
childbed fever
therefore the inflammation caused the
fever
but that's not necessarily true
yes yes the inflammation comes first and
the fever
so it seems like the inflammation causes
the fever
but by that logic since babies usually
grow hair before
teeth hair growth must cause tooth
growth
and we all know that's not true right
actually don't answer that
a couple of different things could be
going on here
first it's possible that fever and
inflammation
are correlated purely by coincidence
or there could be a causal relationship
that's the opposite of what you
think the fever causes the inflammation
rather than the inflammation causing the
fever
or both could share a common underlying
cause
you haven't thought of if i may
just what do you think causes
inflammation
nothing it just is
really humor me for a moment in
discussing one of your colleagues
ideas dr oliver wendell holmes
i know i know you don't like his theory
you already wrote a scathing letter
about it
but let's fill your students in shall we
holmes noticed a pattern when a patient
dies of childbed fever a doctor performs
an autopsy
if the doctor then treats a new patient
that patient often comes down with the
fever
based on this correlation between
autopsies of
fever victims and new fever patients
he proposes a possible cause since
there's no evidence that the autopsy
causes the fever beyond this correlation
he doesn't jump to the conclusion that
autopsy
causes fever instead he suggests
that doctors are infecting their
patients
via an invisible contaminant on their
hands and
surgical instruments this idea
outrages most doctors who see themselves
as
infallible like meeks here
who refuses to consider the possibility
that he's playing a role
in his patients plight his flawed
argument
doesn't leave any path forward for
further investigation
but holmes does
[Music]
it's 1847 and physician ignaz simulvise
has reduced the number of childbed fever
deaths in a clinic from 12
to 1 by requiring all medical personnel
to disinfect their hands
after autopsies and between patient
examinations
with this initiative he has proven the
contagious nature
of child dead fever
[Music]
it's 1879 and louis pasteur has
identified the contaminant responsible
for many
cases of childbed fever hemolytic
streptococcus
bacteria
[Music]
my fries are cold must be because my
ice cream melted
so do you think you can do my job
let's find out shall we click here to
see if you can outsmart
this fallacy
[Music]
you